♪ [music] ♪
In these last few sessions,
we've laid a foundations for the mechanics
of discounted cash flow valuation,
cash flows, growth rates, discount rates,
terminal value, how to bring it all
together by tying up the loose ends.
In this session, I'd like to talk about
going through the mechanics to actually
valuing a company. Now, when we talk about
valuation, especially in the discounted
cash flow sense, we tend to get caught up
in the specifics, the mechanics
of valuation. But I'd like to step back
and talk about what I think is the hidden
ingredient in good valuations.
A good valuation is a bridge
between stories and numbers.
What I mean by that is,
to value a company, you have to start
with a story about the company.
And that story has to become the
numbers that you see in a valuation.
In a good valuation, when you
point to a number in a discounted
cash flow valuation and you ask,
"Why is that number what it is?"
The answer should always be the story you
tell about the company that explains
that number. Good valuations connect
stories to numbers. And people who are
good at valuation tend to be good
storytellers, can also do the
number crunching. Let me back up.
Remember the Vale valuation I showed you?
There was a story behind that valuation.
The story I was telling about Vale was it
was a mature company with significant
comparative advantages.
Mature company showing up in the low
growth rate, the 2% growth rate
in perpetuity, and a company with
significant comparative advantages because
I assumed it would earn a 17.25%
return in capital in perpetuity.
So let me set up the story I'm going to
tell about Disney and convert that story
into valuation. The story I'm going to
tell about Disney is that it's a company
that it's set in its ways.
With the status quo,
I'm going to assume that the company is
going to continue to do what it does,
which is, it earns more than its cost of
capital because it has significant
comparative advantages,
reinvest fairly aggressively for a
large company, about 54% a year.
And because it is going to be able to grow
at a growth rate faster than
the growth rate of the economy,
I'm going to assume a 10-year growth
period. The story I'm telling about Disney
here is an optimistic one.
Perhaps not as optimistic as some
people's stories, but more optimistic
than others. You see that reflected
in the numbers. Over the 10-year
growth period, here's how I came
up with the numbers.
For the first five years,
I left the numbers at 2012, 2013 numbers.
What do I mean by that?
I left the return in capital and
reinvestment rate at what they were in the
most recent year. The story I'm telling
is what company said in its words.
Those numbers give me a growth rate of
6.8% a year for the first five years.
I also assume that even though we have
estimated that Disney has excess
debt capacity, its existing management
will continue to keep its debt ratio
at what it is today, 11.6% debt ratio
and a cost of capital of 7.81%.
So for the next five years, the story
I'm telling is a status quo story.
What happens after year five?
Well, I actually go to year 11 to look
at what my mature Disney will look like,
a lower return on capital of 10%,
a lower growth rate of 2.5%,
and a cost of capital of 7.29%.
The year 6 through 10 that you see for
Disney are really transition years.
So here's what I want my transition phase
to do. I want to use my transition phase,
year 6 through 10, to adjust my numbers
from where they are in the first 5 years
to where I think they will be after
year 10. So let me take an example.
Remember my growth rate for my first five
years is 6.8%, reflecting my assumption
that Disney will continue to do what
they've done in the last year,
54% reinvestment rate and a return in
capital of 12.6%? The growth rate I'm
assuming after year 10 is 2.5%. Here's
what happened between years 6 and 10.
My growth rate decreases from 6.8% to 2.5%
in linear increments. Why linear?
This is the simplest way I could get the
growth rate down. I do that with each and
every one of my assumptions.
My return on capital of 12.61% drops
in linear increments to 10% by year 11.
My cost of capital of 7.81% drops
in linear increments to 7.29% after year
10. So year 6 through 10 are there just
as a transition period to get me from high
growth numbers to stable growth numbers.
These numbers are what drive my valuation
of a company. When I do valuations,
I like to present my valuations not at
spreadsheets but as pictures.
And this is my valuation picture for
Disney. So let's take a look
at the numbers. Let's start at the very
top. I start with my base year numbers.
My free cash flow to the firm in the most
recent year reflects what Disney did
in the most recent year.
They earned a $6.92 billion after-tax
operating income and they reinvested
$3.732 billion of that $6.92 billion back
into the company. That's what gave me a
reinvestment rate of 54% and a return
in capital of 12.61%.
So those are my base year numbers.
I've assumed, for the next five years,
they will maintain those numbers.
Maintaining a return on capital of 12.61%
and a reinvestment rate of close to 54%
gives me an expected growth rate of
6.8% a year for the next five years.
Now, if you go below the line,
you see my existing cost of capital.
And there, again, the number should be
familiar because these are numbers we've
revisited before. I start with the beta of
1.0013 that reflects the five businesses
that Disney is in, the bottom-up beta.
I used a risk-free rate of 2.75%.
That's U.S. T-bond rate as of November of
2013. And I used a risk premium of 5.76%,
reflecting where Disney does its business.
The cost of equity I arrive at based
on those inputs is 8.52%.
The debt ratio of 88.5% equity,
11.5% debt, reflects Disney's choices in
2013, which I have assumed they will
continue to make for the next five years.
The cost of debt based on their rating is
2.4% after taxes. My cost of capital of
7.81% reflects Disney's existing policy
on debt, which I assume they will
continue for the next five years.
What I'm trying to point out here is every
number year can be traced back
to an assumption that we've made about
Disney at an earlier stage in the process.
Between years 6 and 10,
I bring the company down to mature growth.
In mature growth, I give the company a
2.5% growth rate at 10% return on capital
and a reinvestment rate of 25%.
I also bring its cost of capital
down to 7.29%. Those numbers give me a
terminal value of close to a $190 billion.
That's in year 10. I discount my cash
flows, the cash flows for the next 5 years
and beyond between year 6 and 10,
and the terminal value back at the 7.81%
for the first 5 years. But remember,
after year five, my cost of capital also
declines to 7.29%. This is a valuation
where the numbers are in motion and you
got to reflect that in your valuation.
What I get as a present value of all of my
cash flows including my terminal value,
is a $125.48 billion. I add cash.
I also add the non-operating investment
of cross-holding that Disney has,
which is worth about $2.8 billion.
I subtract out debt,
and I subtract out a minority interest.
This reflects the portion of a subsidiary
that's been consolidated that doesn't
belong to them. So the cross-holding
effect shows up in two places. Once,
as an add-on for a minority investment
of cross-holding in another company
that's a minority investment,
and the second as a subtraction to reflect
the consolidation of a subsidiary where
Disney does not own a 100%.
I get a value for the equity
of $113.6 billion. I subtract out the
value of the equity options that Disney
has granted, and it's not a big number.
Disney is a mature company and it's not a
huge drag on its value.
You subtract out the value of those equity
options and you divide by the actual
number of shares. Again, reminder,
if you subtract other value of equity
options, don't double-count by using a
diluted count for the number of shares.
The value per share that I get is $62.26.
This is an intrinsic valuation of Disney
reflecting my status quo story that they
would continue to do what they did in 2012
and 2013. Presenting a valuation as a
picture is a good exercise because it
forces you to see the numbers in your
valuation and how they are all linked to
each other. I don't like using this word
but I will use it, nevertheless.
A good valuation should be holistic.
Every number should be connected to every
other number. So when you want to change
a number, you got to think through the
consequences. And based on my status
quo story, the value per share
that I have for Disney is $62.26.
The stock was actually trading at about
$68. That's within the margin of error.
So my judgment, in November of 2013,
would have been that Disney is close
to fairly value. So you have everything
you need to bring your valuation
to fruition now. Start with the story
you're telling about your company.
Connect that story to the numbers
you've used in your valuation.
Finish your valuation and see if
you can present it as a picture.
You're well on your way to
being a valuation guru.
♪ [music] ♪